we are all trying to preserve the rich
diversity of european countries
because if that diversity is suppressed
we shall weaken europe not strengthen it
the founders of the european community
wanted to draw strength from that
diversity they fully recognized the
scale of the task
but their aims were much more ambitious
than just a materialistic vision
a european war was to be made not just
unlikely but unthinkable
we have to strengthen the ability of
europeans
to act on a european basis where the
nature of a problem requires a european
response
war has not been banished from the
european continent
i think particularly of the war-torn
republics of what used to be yugoslavia
the healing process symbolized by
strasbourg remains badly needed
elsewhere
we have witnessed the triumph of
democracy and the demise of dictatorship
in central europe
with the collapse of the berlin wall the
iron curtain has fallen
our task now is to tend and nurture the
green shoots of a democratic spring
the community is especially well suited
to this task the new members are
knocking at the door
we should be confident of opening it to
them
we must ensure that the friendship and
mutual respect
which we have built among ourselves
should extend more widely throughout our
continent
and enrich our relations with the wider
world
it is a worthy ambition
true to the conviction and example of
the founding fathers of the community
[Music]
you